[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue pour notre dernier rendez vous de
la semaine sera t-il le plus passionnant
eh bien on le saura d'ici quelques
minutes quand c'est le deux invités
bonsoir fer canadien vous êtes un
analyste en politiques publiques à
l'iref le think tank libéral bien connu
de nos internautes
vous êtes aussi délégué général de
l'académie des sciences humaines bonsoir
guillaume bernard bonsoir guillaume vous
êtes maître de conférences à l'institut
catholique d'études supérieures et nos
internautes savent que vous avez co
écrit un ouvrier
ça s'appelle l'empereur et les brigands
c'est aux nouvelles éditions latines et
c'est sous la forme d'une pièce de
théâtre absolu comme si vous aviez
expliqué la semaine dernière la semaine
et dans librairie dans une dizaine de
jours
très bien alors encore un peu de
patience chers internautes c'est un
chiffre impressionnant dont la portée
symbolique est évidemment très forte la
france a atteint les 100 mille morts de
lakovic 19 cents mille décès donc depuis
le début de la pandémie il y a
maintenant plus d'un an
est ce que ce chiffre au delà de sa
dimension symbolique justifie une prise
de parole spécifique des pouvoirs
publics ou même une forme de
commémoration et coûté deux points de
vue pour vous aider à vous faire le
vôtre
d'abord celui de sébastien chenu c'est
la tête de liste du rassemblement
national pour les élections régionales
c'est aussi un député du nord au moment
où on a dépassé les cent mille morts
dans notre pays
je pense qu'ils veulent macron devrait
présenter des excuses aux français
je pense que le minimum serait au moment
se pose même la question d'un hommage
national serait le président de la
république présente des excuses aux
français excuses oui des excuses pour la
façon dont il a géré lamentablement
cette crise je crois que ce serait le
minimum c'est ce qu'on est en droit
d'attendre crois qu'on n'a pas assez en
recueillir de ce qui se passe dans notre
pays je crois que nous sommes lanterne
rouge sur les vaccinations nous
déplorons plus de cent mille morts je
crois que le président de la république
devrait reconnaître qu'il s'est trompé
de chemin plusieurs fois
alors sans aller jusqu'à la présentation
d'excusés aux olivier faure le patron du
parti socialiste est lui favorable à une
forme de 2,2 d'acceptation par le
président de ses responsabilités
or effectivement un hommage à leur
rendre et le président a sa part de
responsabilité évidemment je ne sais pas
si c'est une question d' excuse mais ce
qui est certain c'est qu'il doit prendre
lui aussi la dimension j'ai l'impression
parfois que il est dans un dans une
forme de l'insoutenable légèreté
voilà et la prise de position du
président de la république eh bien la
voilà elle était sous forme d'un tweet
hier soir depuis le début de la pandémie
écrit emmanuel macron 100000 françaises
et français ont succombé au virus
nous avons tous une pensée pour leurs
familles leurs proches pour leurs
enfants qui ont perdu un parent ou un
grand parent les fratries en deuil et
les amitiés faucher guillaume bernard
c'est un acquis son ressenti finalement
assez subjective est ce que est ce qu il
faut y avoir une forme de 2,2 de
sacralisation des chiffres quand ils
sont aussi impressionnants alors
sincèrement je le crois pas j'avoue que
je suis un peu étonné par un tel débat
me semble qu'on rend hommage qu'on rende
des honneurs à des personnes
lorsqu'elles ont un mérite particulier
or là en l'occurrence sont des personnes
pour qui j'ai la plus parfaite des
compassions et pour leur famille
naturellement parce que ce sont des
personnes qui sont décédées
mais je ne vois pas en quoi il y aurait
à mérite particulier pour ces personnes
de malades et qui sont finalement
décédée donc sincèrement je ne vois
vraiment pas en quoi il pourrait y avoir
une justification pour un hommage
national à c'est à ces morts sont pas
des héros par exemple comme elles sont
les gens qui sont morts pour la france
pendant un conflit militaire exactement
est donc évidemment pas et donc dans ces
conditions ça me paraît ubuesque
d'envisager cela ou même d'en débattre
et les
les prises de position qu'on a entendu
du rassemblement national du parti
socialiste me semble être plus je dirais
de la tambouille politicienne
essayez de taper sur le président de la
république ce qui en soit me dérange pas
trop où je dois bien le reconnaître mais
enfin c'est quand même un peu je dirais
étape est en dessous de la ceinture et
et pas discuté du vrai problème qui me
semble être celui justement de l'analyse
des chiffres parce que cent mille morts
mais tout de même ce sont des personnes
pour beaucoup semble-t-il qui avaient
une espérance de vie qui était
extrêmement courte et puis ces cent
mille morts qui sont décédés donc avec
locaux vides mais est ce qu elles sont
véritablement des cd du coc vidé ce
qu'elle n'y avait pas une comorbidité
comme on dit qui explique que
effectivement elles soient décédés donc
voilà je trouve sincèrement qu on est là
dans du pathos et pas dans une analyse
rationnelle de la situation et il me
semble que le plus grave dans la
situation actuelle c'est que on est un
pays qui meurt on est dans une france
assassiné que ce soit la france des
petits commerçants des restaurateurs ou
tout simplement la france je dirais deux
comme dirait philippe de villiers du
voisinage qui est en train de mourir
et ça ça me paraît encore plus grave
votre propos reflètent assez bien le
point de vue de nos internautes vous
posons la question sur twitter faut-il
rendre hommage aux 100000 mort du co
vide 19 ou de la coved 19 comme on
voudra si l'on suit ou non les
recommandations de l'académie française
est bien en tout cas à cette question la
réponse est non à 55%
marie sur twitter nous dire anton
hommage aux morts du cancer à tous ceux
qui attendent des greffes aux accidentés
de la route non responsable je trouve
cela indécent et inapproprié l'idée d'un
hommage dit nicole 0,6
nathan 770 constate sur lefigaro.fr pour
le déplorer que manuel macro incapable
de faire un hommage sur n'importe quel
sujet la contrition est une spécialité
républicaine serge gainsbourg ou alors
c'est sans doute par le vrai sur youtube
nous dit on rendra hommage à cent mille
personnes alors que la peste noire a
fait des millions de morts et a tué la
moitié de la population de l'europe à
réfléchir
et puis nicole 06 toujours on rend
hommage à quelqu'un pour un acte pas
pour le fait d'être victime d'une
maladie sagana diaries on comprend bien
ce point de vue effectivement les morts
de la commune 19 sont plus des victimes
que des roses qui n'enlève rien
évidemment alors valeurs personnelles
mais en même temps on sent que le pays
est bouleversée par tous ces morts donc
est ce que dans une forme de devoir d'
empathie le président de la république
ne doit pas se manifester
l'empathie oui mais maintenant je ne
vois pas effectivement pourquoi cette
empathie se confondent avec l'hommage
puisque comme l'a tout à fait comme l'a
dit guillaume bernard l'hommage est bien
éduqué de rigueur lorsqu'on est face à
des personnalités méritantes or aussi
triste que cela puisse être mourir du
covin n'est pas en soi un acte héroïque
donc c'est vrai que je ne comprends pas
très bien ce que vient faire le
vocabulaire de l'hommage et la
commémoration ici d'autant plus que j'ai
pour ma part la désagréable impression
qu'il s'agit d'une diversion pour ne pas
avoir à parler du mot responsabilité car
si en effet moi je ne refuse à parler de
dommages
je ne crois pas qu'il soit démagogique
de parler de responsabilité de la classe
politique puisque faut-il le rappeler
c'est cent mille morts alors bien sûr et
une partie de ces morts qui sont
imputables à des à des catastrophes
naturelles qui sont
difficilement qu'on peut difficilement
mettre sur le dos de la classe politique
française maintenant au delà d'une
certaine face quand on a un vaccin qui
est disponible quand on voit que dans le
voisinage français c'est à dire que le
royaume uni train de réouvrir cette
activité que le nombre
d'hospitalisations baisse dans les pays
comme israël s'ils ont mené une campagne
de vaccination exemplaires et bien là il
ya une question qui peut se poser c'est
qu'elle parmi ces cent mille morts eh
bien quelle part peut être imputée
finalement à la négligence de la classe
politique et à son incapacité à avoir
mené une politique de vaccination
correct et c'est là dessus
à mon avis qu'il aurait fallu aller
plutôt que de parler d'un hommage qui
pour moi constitue une diversion on peut
voir peut-être les des images des
hommages qui ont été rendus aux états
unis aux très nombreux morts de la
pandémie peut ils sont plus nombreux
qu'en france bien sûr
compte tenu de l'importance de la
population du pays
guillaume bernard vous n'êtes pas
sensible à ce genre d'image surtout que
compte tenu des du contexte sanitaire
les gens qui sont morts de la copie ou
d'autres causes d'ailleurs ont été
enterrés souvent dans l'intimité avec
très peu de gens et que donc il ya
peut-être un besoin d'une forme de de
commémoration collective pour pallier
cette ce manque d'écouté dans ce cas là
c'est les mesures qui ont été prises par
le gouvernement qui sont fautives
ça ne rend pas pour autant mérite encore
une fois les personnes qui sont décédées
de cette maladie ou avec cette maladie
parce que je crois que
il faut pouvoir discuter sereinement
sereinement d'aider des chiffres et moi
il me semble vraiment que c'est du
pathos qui est utilisé pour pouvoir
justifier peut être moins les mesures
pas c'est que comme le dit fergane ou
oubliées les mesures passées où les
négligences passé que pour justifier les
mesures futures
le pass sanitaire qui effectivement nous
pend au nez si j'ose dire si vous me
permettez l'expression un peu un peu
familière et qui me paraît être
extrêmement extrêmement dangereux je
crains que parce que tous les jours on
entend de nouvelles informations
concernant la vaccination ce matin même
si je ne m'abuse on nous a dit que ça il
faudrait peut-être une troisième dose et
puis que la vaccination allait durer des
années qu'il faudrait sans arrêt avoir
de nouveaux vaccins
voilà je crains que l'on ne soit rentré
dans un processus hygiéniste qui soit
extrêmement dangereux pour et
l'intégrité physique des personnes et
les libertés les libertés publiques donc
je je je pense que malheureusement alors
je ne suis pas un spécialiste de
communication politique mais je pense
que malheureusement on peut envisager
que ce soit 1 une des méthodes qui
souhaitent utiliser pour pouvoir et bien
dramatiser la situation pour faire
accepter d'autant plus facilement par la
population des mesures qui seront prises
par la suisse ce bilan de 100 milliards
nous avons ne nous a pas fait changer
d'avis sur le vaccin vous ne vous ferai
pas vacciner avant ma part si je peux y
échapper je le ferai au maximum pour
deux raisons d'abord parce qu'il ya des
vaccins dits normaux mais qui sont
encore expérimentaux on le sait bien les
séquelles susceptibles que nous sommes
susceptibles de subir à cause de ces
vaccins ne seront pas indemnisés par les
fabricants de ces vaccins mais par la
puissance publique ce qui me paraît
totalement ubuesque
et puis la deuxième raison c'est qu'il y
a des vaccins nouveaux qui ne sont pas
de vrais vaccins qui sont attentatoires
au fonctionnement habituel du corps
humain les
les vaccins avec arn messagers et donc
cela je n'en veux évidemment pas parce
que c'est une
c'est une commande ya c'est un doigt a
mis dans l'engrenage du transhumanisme
ferghana diaries vous êtes sensible à
cet argument selon lequel le nombre de
morts et le côté spectaculaire de ses
cent mille décès serait un moyen pour
faire pression sur les français
notamment pour qui se vaccinent le plus
possible je ne sais pas si c'est une
stratégie délibérée je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les français sont
sensibles à ces cent mille morts
sans forcément qu'il y ait une
machination médiatique derrière pour
nous émouvoir au risque au risque de
d'un visibiliser aussi bas le fait que
la copie n'est pas forcément la
pathologie qui tue le plus dans le monde
ya la pauvreté qui tue beaucoup plus de
gens que quotidiennement alors ça se
chiffrant en millions d'années de vie
perdues chaque année mais ça n'émeut
personne pourquoi parce que on efface
ici à une catastrophe naturelle qui tue
de manière immédiate donc on a un impact
qui est très concentré à la fois dans le
temps et dans l'espace
là où les autres fléaux tu de manière
beaucoup plus diffuse dans l'espace et
dans le temps personne ne fera jamais sa
une sur tel ou tel commerçant qui a vu
son espérance de vie réduite de deux à
trois ans par ce choix il s'est enfoncé
dans une misère qui fait qu'il n'a pas
été capable de diagnostiquer telle ou
telle maladie
donc il ya une espèce de d'effets
pervers qui fait qu'on on prête beaucoup
d'attention aux corridors ce qui est
bien mais en même temps on tend aussi à
négliger que c'est loin d'être est bien
le seul fléau le seul problème qui
accablent aujourd'hui les individus en
france et dans le monde je rappelle
quand même que il y a quelques mois
n'est des instances onusiennes déplorait
plus de 500 millions de gens retomber
dans la misère à cause de la pandémie
il est tout à fait possible que ces 500
millions de gens tomber dans la misère
finalement bien conduisent à une perte
d'espérance de vie supérieure à une
pandémie comme la kfw qui tuerait 1 % de
l'humanité mais savoyen que personne
n'en parle mais que personne ne propose
dommages sur la question pour revenir à
ce que disait très brièvement sur les
vaccins je ne suis pas d'accord avec
newman a continué
is l'utilité de la vaccination pour bien
comprendre qu'aujourd'hui si on veut en
tout cas retrouver une vie normale en
minimisant tout simplement les
souffrances qui accable aujourd'hui le
genre humain je crois que le rapport
coût bénéfice est tout à fait favorable
à la vaccination
donc on va pas j'encouragerai plutôt les
français à se vacciner pour eux et pour
leurs proches
je pars relancer mais robot j'aime
beaucoup le coupé les fils on est chez
bentham 1 et je crains malheureusement
que la société du tout vaccin et du pass
à lithaire ce soit plus le panoptique
n'est ce pas que la société que la lente
et les jambes la société libre pour les
jambes peut cultiver comment qui ne
savent pas qu'ils aient benta bentham
c'est jérémy malte à nous méfier des
mandataires de l'utilitarisme et il a
inventé un type de prison où on ne sait
jamais si l'on est surveillé mais comme
on est toujours susceptible d'être
surveillés et bien en fait on se tient
on se tient extrêmement c'est quand même
mon dos il honnêtement alors revenir la
société normale avec le pass sanitaire
ça me parait dresse une bas total
normale sup et perméable aux opa
sanitaire je pense qu'on peut persuader
les français et les gens de manière
générale à se vacciner de manière
volontaire qu'on peut miser sur la
responsabilité individuelle sans faire
appel pour la coercition je suis tout
aussi opposé que vous à une coercition
étatique en la matière mais ce n'est pas
incompatible avec le fait d'en appeler à
la responsabilité individuelle et
collective des gens pour cela et je me
souviens notamment d'un débat que nous
avions eu tous les trois sur
l'obligation possible pour le personnel
médical de se faire vacciner là pour le
coup vous y montriez favorable aux
banques serait ce contrat est absolument
écoutez nos internautes s'en sont tous
réticents en tout cas tous ceux qui
s'expriment
cet après midi sur cette idée d'un
hommage il n'y a jamais eu dommages lors
des quinze mille morts de la canicule en
france tout dit un anonyme sur
lefigaro.fr marais cliquez sur
lefigaro.fr toujours le calendrier de
365 jours est trop restreint pour tous
les jours de tout et n'importe quoi trop
dommage tu le sens de l'hommage
et puis avec respect nous dit il faut
être très humble par rapport à tous ces
maux
on change de sujet si vous voulez bien
vous vous souvenez que c'était l'une des
mesures phares de la réforme du bac
voulue par le ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer
la mise en oeuvre d'un grand oral
un grand oral qui devait durer vingt
minutes et qui aurait pu compter pour 10
% de la note totale du bac général 20
minutes avec un exposé puis un échange
entre le jury et l'élève notamment sur
ses projets professionnels pourquoi
est-ce que je mets tous et
conditionnellement parce que en 2020 ce
grand oral n'a pas pu être mise en place
et pour cause puisque les épreuves du
bac n'ont pas eu lieu pour cause de
pandémie
c'est le contrôle continu qui a tenu
lieu des preuves
et puis pour cette année il n'est pas
non plus du tout évident que ce grand
oral puisse être mis en place il ya des
vrais opposition chez les syndicats
d'enseignants par exemple à l'unsa dont
la secrétaire nationale expliqué sur rtl
il ya quelques jours que personne n'est
préparé à ce grand oral qui a un manque
de formation des enseignants et par
conséquent des élèves aussi et puis
il ya une pétition qui circule contre la
tenue de ce grand oral pétition lancée
par des lycéens et qui a déjà recueilli
26 mille signatures alors mon avis quand
tout le monde a des des lycéens pour
savoir s'ils veulent travailler ou pas
pas sûr qu'ils aient beaucoup de
pétitionnaires qui s'y oppose mais enfin
ça c'est un point de vue personnel
celle ci arrive sur le fond vous êtes
plutôt pour plutôt content le maintien
de cette ce grand oral
écoutez je trouve étrange qu'on soit pas
capable d'inventer des dispositifs pour
faire en sorte que ce grand oral se
passe dans les meilleures conditions
possibles est ce qu'aujourd'hui
compte tenu du fait qu'on a un peu plus
de recul sur la manière dont ce virus se
transmet compte tenu de l'usagé
nouvelles technologies et il n'est pas
possible de d'aménager là encore les
choses pour permettre à ses étudiants de
passer le grand oral donc l'argument
sanitaire me me dérange puisque j'ai
quand même l'impression que le problème
n'est pas si insurmontable que ça alors
peut-être que je me trompe peut-être que
les gens qui sont sur le terrain sont
mieux placés mais enfin du point de vue
de l'un black ops à la tant que je suis
j'avoue que j'ai du mal à comprendre les
raisons sanitaires maintenant je pense
aussi qu'il faut arrêter de surestimer
l'utilité et l'importance des épreuves
de baccalauréat
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui bon c'est un
diplôme qui est devenu une espèce de
comment dire de procédure un peu les
grands établissements aujourd'hui
organise l'euro cotant de manière
différente
il se base sur le contrôle continu
quelquefois ils mettent en place leur
propre système de sélection leur propre
concours de sorte que le baccalauréat a
déjà perdu en fait son rôle de sélection
et d'accréditation des candidats qui
postulent pour telle ou telle carrière
tel ou tel cursus donc on supprimerait
carrément comme je pense que l'utilité
du baccalauréat a toujours été un peu
discutable on se souvient que d'ailleurs
les raisons pour lesquelles il a été
instauré n'était pas tout à fait
bienveillante puisque lorsque napoléon
le met en place à l'époque s'agit de
verrouiller tout un système
d'enseignement en mettant en place un
monopole de l'état sur la manière de
sélectionner les professeurs avec
l'université impériale donc faire du
baccalauréat l'alpha et l'oméga de la
méritocratie me semble historiquement
douteux est factuellement incorrect je
pense qu'aujourd'hui le fait le fait est
que les les grandes écoles les
établissements les professions ont leur
propre manière et bien d'organiser la
sélection des candidats et que le
baccalauréat de ce point de vue là est
devenu un instrument assez dérisoire en
tout cas pour signaler que l'aptitude
d'un candidat pour suivre des études
supérieures
je précise que le ministère a jusqu'au
1er juin pour se prononcer sur ce
maintien ou non du grand oral si vous
étiez le ministre guillaume bernard que
feriez vous je crois qu'il ya plusieurs
aspects il ya la question de l'épreuve
où le contrôle continu pour le
baccalauréat bon je l' ai déjà dit ici
moi je suis plutôt favorable aux
épreuves d'examens et de concours plus
que pour le contrôle continu
parce qu'il me semble que tout
simplement c'est expérimenté pour les
lycéens pour les étudiants et bien le
fait d'être confronté un jour à un
moment donné à un sujet à traiter comme
on l'est tous dans la vie
professionnelle
à confronter on est tous confrontés
évidemment à un certain nombre de
dossiers de dossiers à traiter
bon ensuite il ya le deuxième aspect
c'est le contenu même de cette épreuve
d'une partie de l'opposition des
enseignants à cette épreuve c'est
qu'elle est telle qu'elle est l'objet de
cette de cette épreuve
quelle quelle est la matière qui est
véritablement traité qu'elle de quelle
discipline s'agit-il et là effectivement
je ne serais sans doute pas conduit à
utiliser les mêmes les mêmes arguments
que nos amis syndicalistes en disant
qu'on n'est pas formé à elle me semble
quand même que si on est enseignant
agrégé à priori pour enseigner dans le
lycée devrait quand même être capables
d'une certaine souplesse
donc il me semble que là pour le coup
c'est plutôt une diversion de leur part
mais en revanche une vraie question
c'est est ce qu'on n'est pas en train de
commentaires de 2,2 de supprimer petit à
petit je dirais de grignoter dans le
fond le fait que dans le baccalauréat
dans le premier grade universitaire
puisque je voudrais revenir là dessus
parce que faire gagnent en a parlé c'est
très important
c'est le premier grade universitaire en
france d'où le monopole de l'état via
risque on n'est pas en train de
grignoter
je dirais les matières les disciplines
l'histoire la géographie la philosophie
le français les mathématiques etc donc
des vrais enseignements et des vrais
savoir contre simplement une discussion
à bâtons rompus sur tel ou tel grand
principe ou sur les ambitions des
lycéens dont je dois dire que pour en
recevoir
il y en avoir reçu un assez grand nombre
ces dernières années lorsqu'il le
postulait pour rentrer dans mon
université où là il ya effectivement une
sélection et notamment un entretien
ben il faut bien reconnaître que à la
sortie du bac ou en train de passer le
bac
ils n'ont pas pu malheureusement
beaucoup d'idées sur ce qu'ils veulent
faire par la suite
dans le domaine professionnel donc voilà
le fait que l'on
comment dire que l'on maintienne
l'épreuve moi j'y suis a priori plutôt
pour
j'y suis d'autant plus attachée que je
pense qu'il faut que et les étudiants du
public et du sous contrat et les
étudiants du hors contrats soient
traités de la même manière
n'est ce pas et que qu'ils passent tous
les mêmes épreuves jouables nice l'a
expliqué très bien une coche signé qui
est alors à la tête de l'organisation
créer son école mais il y a l'autre
aspect des choses c'est le contenu de
l'épreuve
et là pour le coup je suis plus
dubitatif je suis quand même plutôt
favorable à ce que l'on est des épreuves
portant sur des vraies matière avec un
vrai programme avec des vraies
connaissances un vrai savoir dont il
s'agit de vérifier si le lycéen ou
l'étudiant ont ou non les connaissances
et pas simplement sur sa psychologie ou
sur ces ou sur ses ambitions
ça me paraît là pour le coup pas adapté
si je peux rebondir sur ce que ferghana
dit oui bien sûr qu évidemment le
baccalauréat n'a plus du tout le même
rôle social qu'il avait
il ya une cinquantaine d'années parce
qu'effectivement c'était difficile de
l'obtenir et c'était un sas d'entrée
vers les études universitaires ce qui
n'est plus aujourd'hui on sait très bien
qu'aujourd'hui finalement et bien une
fois attendre plutôt la fin de la
licence de plaine ce qu'on appelle la
licence iii pour je dirais la avoir un
certain d'écrémage il voir ce qu'ils ont
réussi à continuer des études et validé
leur examen ou pas bon il n'empêche que
dans le système français actuel le
baccalauréat est toujours le premier des
grades universitaires
le baccalauréat la licence depuis 1999
le master est devenu un grade
universitaire et enfin le doctorat et à
partir du moment où c'est un grade
universitaire il y a une responsabilité
de l'état puisque l'état prétend imposer
un monopole de ses propres
fonctionnaires pour pouvoir attribuer ou
non ce diplôme qui est un grade
universitaire et dans ces conditions là
on ne peut pas traiter ces questions là
par dessus la jambe
donc je crois que il faudrait
véritablement alors je pense que fergane
pour m a prouvé de ce point de vue là
introduire une certaine liberté de
fonctionnement dans le système
d'instruction en france et la belle rama
lol et mettre à mal le monopole de la
grenade lors de la collation étatique
des grades universitaires
c'est à dire que
que l'état soit garant que ce soit a
effectivement un niveau minimum qu'ils
soient assurés mais qui ne soit pas
imposé je dirais le double monopole
c'est à dire l'état qui surveille qui
garantit de l'est qui en plus impose que
ce soit ses propres agents et ses
propositions et ses propres critères qui
déterminent effectivement ce qu'est un
grade universitaire et ça c'est il ya un
très très bon article du professeur près
l'eau dans la rdp la revue de droit
public qui démontre de manière
absolument clair et net que healy à
double aspect il ya le fait que l'état
soit le garant du maître étalon inquiète
à sèvres n'est ce pas comme tout le
monde mais bon voilà
et pourquoi pas le bagne aussi et ya le
fait qu'il impose le fait que ce soit
ces agents qui soit dépositaire du
pouvoir d'attribuer ou non des grades
universitaires et ça en revanche c'est
un véritable c'est un véritable problème
parce que ça laisse entendre dans le
fond que seuls les agents publics sont
en capacité de pouvoir jauger de la
qualité intellectuelle des étudiants ce
qui me paraît un tout petit peu
discutable vous êtes presque dépassé
dans votre libéralisme par guillaume
bernard ganne asia oui bah sur les quais
son enseignement je pense qu on se
rejoint sur le fait que le monopole est
toujours une mauvaise chose alors ok au
berner peut-être déteste ce monopole
étatique pour une autre raison puisqu'il
est celle obtenue à l'époque contre
l'église catholique il s'agissait
d'extirper complètement l'autorité
ecclésiastique du de l'enseignement mais
c'est plus du droit naturel pour le coup
la défense d'une coque corporatiste
catholique
c'est le principe de subsidiarité tout
débat sur ce point fait il mention
l'importance de la liberté
d'enseignement et le fait qu'aujourd'hui
le monopole de la collation des grades
est aussi responsable de d'une espèce
d'une industrie de l'enseignement était
complètement sclérosé et qui d'ailleurs
intéresse aussi la question sanitaire
puisque vous savez que healy a en france
par exemple des dispositifs comme les
numerus clausus qui font que eh bien le
nombre de médecins illimité sur le
territoire mais il ya aussi de
l'impossibilité d'ouvrir une école de
médecine privée par exemple ont formé
plus de professionnels et tout ça est
lié au monopole de la collation des
grades puisque l'état s'est arrogé le
monopole la certification des
compétences des uns et des autres ce qui
n'a strictement aucune utilité sociale
ou économique
à l'époque il faut le dire et c'est
toujours le cas aujourd'hui s'agit de
gouverner les esprits comme le voulait
un napoléon et en ce sens et condorcet
avant lui et condorcet rue beaucoup plus
libéral qu'on en fait quand même ils
étaient beaucoup plus pour la liberté
d'enseignement que que napoléon mais du
point de vue effectivement delà de
l'objectif du système de l'enseignement
à savoir former des citoyens libres et
éclairés et compétents dans les arts et
industries dans lesquelles ils veulent
s'engager le monopole de l'état ne se
justifie pas et bien ça nous a emmenés
vers des horizons qu'on n'avait pas
forcément prévu ce thème de du maintien
ou non du grand oral du baccalauréat
mais c'est tout à fait passionnant et
nous certains lautier ce qu'ils en
france mon globalement il pense qu'il
faut sauver ce conte orales du
baccalauréat c'est oui à 61 % lors de ce
questionnaire que nous vous proposons
sur twitter jean paul préféré qu'on
sauve les étudiants faudrait les
sagesses oui alors il ya romano sur
twitter on se demande presque si c'est
ce n est pas votre avatar cher guillaume
besse qui dit exactement chose que vous
il faut rétablir le bac comme diplôme
national avec des vraies épreuves
terminales cette chienlit de grand oral
et de contrôle continu par tous doit
cesser alors vous vous dites pas chiant
lien peut-être parce que ça a été
utilisée par des gens que vous
n'appréciez pas forcément mais je
referme la parenthèse
je rappelle nous dirons mano que le bac
est le premier grade universitaire c'est
quelque chose de sérieux avec respect et
reconnaît avec humilité qui n'a pas
d'avis par contre je trouve que le bac
en france n'a plus beaucoup de valeur
nous dit il et puis nl sur youtube
accompagnement insuffisant épreuve
encore floues conditions sanitaires
hasardeuse ça me paraît compliqué tout
ça si on élargit un petit peu le débat
africain asia reset cette position du
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
s'enorgueillit que la france est
toujours résisté en tout cas le plus
possible et jusqu'à il ya deux semaines
maintenant à la fermeture des écoles ça
il faut tenir bon sur ce ce côté là vie
normale doit continuer mais je pense que
là dessus on a eu raison de ne pas
fermer les écoles pour ne pas sacrifier
davantage les jeunes générations
ce qui n'empêche absolument pas ce
qu'ils craignent cette pandémie sont
vraiment frileux de prendre leurs
responsabilités c'est à dire qu'il faut
laisser encore une fois la liberté aux
établissements aux élèves et bien de
choisir les risques auxquels ils
s'exposent et est de ce point de vue là
ne pas fermer arbitrairement les écoles
donc ne pas priver la possibilité pour
les élèves qui souhaitent c'est les
enseignants qui souhaitent continuer
d'apprendre et d'exercer leur métier en
dépit du contexte pandémique je crois
que c'était un bon choix et qu'il aurait
fallu s'y tenir et puis un dernier mot
sur un autre choix qui a été fait
guillaume bernard celui de d'organiser
le bac par le contrôle continu de
l'année dernière est-ce que du coup
quand vous enseignant
du supérieur vous regarder des dossiers
vous vous dites oh là là attention c'est
quand même une année un peu perdu alors
c'est pas une année perdue mais en
revanche c'est le absolument il est
absolument certain que l'origine du
lycée de l'étudiant content parce que
évidemment il ya des lycées qui sont
réputés pour noter plus ou moins
largement et donc par conséquent on est
obligé d'avoir une grille de lecture des
notes et non pas une prise en
considération des nôtres telles qu'elles
sont telles qu'elles sont indiqués on
sait bien que grosso modo 1 12 dans leur
contrat ça vaut 1 14 ans le sous contrat
ça vaut 1 16
dans le public voilà voilà voilà ce
qu'on appellerait en d'autres lieux une
hiérarchie des normes assez clair merci
beaucoup à tous les deux merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis très bon week-end et
on se retrouve avec grand plaisir lundi
pour un nouveau rendez-vous de point de
vue
[Musique]